Oh  [Music]  mom Who am I  you are a gift we believe that you came  here for a reason  I know it's been difficult for you  lately but you feel different from other  kids  Caitlyn commando he's a creep help him  up  baby theories along with Brandon and now  he's hurting people he's never bled  we're cooking a bone  never turn against our son he's not  [Music]  hey who's messing with me  [Applause]  [Music]  something wrong  boy round by chance one of the only  people in the world that knows how  special I am there are believed to be no  survivors among the 268 passengers on  board  [Music]  inside you  [Music]  at the Braille residence I wanted you  good man I do  [Music]  you